bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à strasbourg pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo
cette semaine on parle bien sûr de la
crise des migrants le grand marchandage
les européens qui rejettent les migrants
vers la turquie
l'homme de la semaine c'est lui ahmet
davutoglu le premier ministre turc à
bruxelles les 28 ont longuement discuté
d'un plan d'action il se traite à ankara
la gestion des migrants un nouveau
conseil est prévue les 17 et 18 mars
pour finaliser l'accord entre l'europe
et la turquie ankara réclame 3 milliards
en plus des 3 milliards déjà consentis
et la libre circulation de ses
ressortissants dans schengen l'actualité
c'est aussi manuel valls qu'il veut
modifier le code du travail en france un
autre pays européen à lancer un train de
réformes c'est l'italie 1 son premier
ministre a d'ailleurs affiché une forme
de complicité similitudes avec le
premier ministre français c'est
l'italien matteo renzi à la réforme du
sénat italien réforme du marché du
travail en italie alors manuel valls
matteo renzi même méthode
c'est ce qu'on va voir en seconde partie
d'émission avec nos invités
sylvie goulard eurodéputée de l'alliance
des démocrates et libéraux pour l'europe
avec mercedes bresso
elle est eurodéputé italienne membre du
parti démocrate al partie de matteo
renzi ça tombe bien
mais d'abord retour sur ce sommet de
bruxelles il est peut être en train
d'accoucher d'un dispositif sans
équivalent la turquie propose de
reprendre tous les migrants qui quittent
ses côtes en échange l'europe ouvrirait
à canal d'admission régulier depuis
depuis le territoire turc et porterait
aussi son aide à 6 milliards d'euros
regardez
tout sourire à met à vous de cloud au
centre des discussions
le premier ministre turc le sait il est
en position de force à bruxelles il a
fait une proposition de taille la
turquie s'engage à reprendre tous les
migrants qui aurait franchi les mailles
du filet et qui arrive en grèce
les migrants économiques mais aussi les
réfugiés syriens
une fois ramenés en turquie les migrants
économiques seraient expulsés par ankara
vers leur pays d'origine sur le sol turc
les réfugiés syriens eux seraient prises
en charge par l'union européenne qui
aurait un guichet d'admission en turquie
et non plus en grèce mais nous avons
pris une décision audacieuse comme je
les dis en acceptant tous les migrants
illégaux venant de turquie en respectant
leur origine et nous les accepterons en
vertu du principe selon lequel pour
chaque syriens réunis en turquie depuis
les îles grecques
un autre syrien sera réinstallé en
europe l'union européenne lire est
recherché en turquie les vrais réfugiés
de guerre syriens et s'engage à
faciliter leur installation légal sur
son territoire objectif dissuader les
migrants de prendre des risques et de
pays des passeurs pour traverser la mer
egée ce plan proposé par les turcs a été
saluée par les 28
s'il est accepté il prendra effet dès le
1er juin
le premier ministre turc a confirmé
s'être engagé à accepter le retour
rapide de tous les migrants allant de
turquie vers la grèce ceux qui n'ont pas
besoin de protection internationale
toutes les décisions que nous avons
prises aujourd'hui envoie un message
très clair le temps de l'immigration
irrégulière en europe est révolu un plan
qui a son prix la turquie réclame non
plus 3 mais 6 milliards d'euros pour
l'aider à prendre en charge ces réfugiés
ankara exige la suppression des visas
pour les turcs qui souhaitent se rendre
en europe et ce dès le mois de juin
prochain
d'accord dit on à bruxelles mais c'est
du donnant donnant dès lors que la
turquie fait ce geste mène cette
politique
conduit cette orientation avec rigueur
alors il peut y avoir ce qu'on appelle
une libéralisation des visas pour les
turcs mais aux règles selon les règles
qui ont été fixées dès l'origine ce
qu'on appelle la feuille de route vise à
enfin la turquie demandent
l'accélération du processus d'adhésion à
l'union européenne
sur tous ces points il y a des
réticences des états membres les 28
secondes ont donné dix jours avant de
signer et d'officialiser leurs nouvelles
relations avec ankara
voilà nous enjoint sur ce plateau sylvie
goulard bonsoir vous êtes eurodéputés de
l'alliance des démocrates et des
libéraux pour l'europe
en france vous avez été élu sous les
couleurs de l'udf et du modem à vos
côtés mercedes bresso bonsoir à vous
êtes eurodéputés italienne membre du
groupe socialiste et démocrate en italie
vous avez été élu sous les couleurs du
parti démocrate et le parti du président
du conseil des ministres matteo renzi
alors on vient de voir le reportage les
migrants c'est le gros dossier
l'europe voudrait que la turquie
récupère une partie des migrants qui
sont en europe et que le filtrage se
fasse en turquie est ce que c'est une
bonne solution sylvie goulard bonsoir je
crois que d'abord votre reportage est
utile parce qu'il fait bien la
différence entre migrants et réfugiés
ce que ce qui est rarement fait dans le
débat public on est confronté à deux
types de situations différentes les
réfugiés sur les personnes qui fuient la
guerre par exemple en syrie et qui ont
droit en vertu de conventions
internationales à une protection
les autres sont des personnes qui vont
chercher un avenir meilleur je dirais
d'ailleurs qu'en soi c'est pas non plus
forcément répréhensible mais qui seront
dans une autre situation juridique
la vraie difficulté si j'ose dire
s'agissant d'êtres humains on parle
d'êtres humains c'est d'opérer ce type
de tri qu'on le fasse en bonne
intelligence avec la turquie pour éviter
que les passeurs met dans des rafiots
des personnes qui vont se noyer
c'est plutôt une bonne chose je suis un
petit peu sceptique sur cette capacité à
prendre des gens à les ramener à les
renvoyer la mise en oeuvre pourrait se
révéler beaucoup plus délicate qu'on ne
croit mercedes bresso vous ne contestait
pas la philosophie du projet puisqu'une
d'une certaine manière ces migrants
économiques et les réfugiés de guerre
aussi qu'ils sont refoulés en turquie
puisque la signature aurait sciemment je
ne pense pas qu'on puisse se prendre un
accord pour renvoyer ceux qui sont déjà
arrivées qui ont été enregistrés qui
sont en train d'être enregistrées en
grèce mais la corde valoir pour pour le
futur ça doit être clair qu'on ne peut
plus traverser la mer et se présenter
d'une façon donc
d'une façon illégale et surtout que
l'objectif de cet accord si on le fera
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à voir
encore l'objectif c'est d'éviter de plus
en plus de stopper complètement coupé
les jambes à la spéculation au trafic
des migrants
ça c'est quelque chose de totalement
helmand qui produit des des milliers de
morts à méditerranée et essayer de le
stopper
c'est très positif on a besoin de la
garde-frontière d'un système de police
commune européenne qui donc frontex
énormément la force et qui qui pourrait
avec la turquie une sphère cette
sélection d'une façon qui garantissent
les droits civils roulant ce qui est un
trouble avec les valeurs aussi
européennes notamment sur le droit
d'asile on avait dit que le droit
d'asile ça devait être traité les
demandeurs d'asile devaient être traités
de façon individuelle individuellement
lassé des refoulements massif ce côté
individuel n'existe plus ce qui est un
problème avec les valeurs européennes
il est évident que la question du
traitement des réfugiés vu leur masse et
vu ce qui est en train de se passer
crée évidemment des tensions avec une
vision qu'on pourrait souhaiter beaucoup
plus respectueuse de la personne humaine
je crois qu'il faut se garder de
simplifier parce que y'a qu'à faire
mieux c'est un peu facile
en revanche mais il ya une chose qui me
frappe si je puis me permettre dans les
relations avec la turquie c'est que ça
ne me semble pas devoir être une raison
pour relancer de manière subreptice et
dans le dos des citoyens européens
le processus d'adhésion parlera prénom
jean claude juncker avait dit dans
l'hémicycle du parlement européen qui ne
progresserait pas dans les cinq ans où
il serait président de la commission
européenne et deuxièmement il ya une
chose beaucoup plus fondamentale sur les
valeurs justement la turquie est membre
depuis 1949 du conseil de l'europe la
turquie est censé respecter la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme ça vaut à la fois pour la
dignité des personnes humaines ça vaut
pour la liberté de la presse
je suis né stupéfié que personne de
parmi nos dirigeants ne fasse allusion
fermement on est à strasbourg juste à
côté du siège de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme et notamment la france
pourrait beaucoup plus souligné que
c'est pas pour faire plaisir à l'union
européenne pour y adhérer que la turquie
doit respecter les droits de l'homme la
turquie est membre
la convention européenne des droits de
l'homme depuis 49 ans a été dit par
notre premier ministre est le seul qui a
prétendu que cette phrase soit inséré
dans le texte de l'accord de son bâti
projet d'accord concernant d'autres
sujets en tout cas la crise des migrants
le président turc dit que lui il
respecte les droits de l'homme puisqu'il
sauver les migrants qui risquent de se
noyer dans la mer avec six essais bateau
il l'a dit c'est du donnant donnant le
président turc recep tayyip erdogan a
pris la parole lors d'un meeting il a
reproché à l'union européenne sa lenteur
à débloquer un fond des 2 3 milliards
d'euros a pour freiner le flux
migratoires vers l'europe 3 milliards
destinés aux 2 millions 700 mille
réfugiés syriens vivant en turquie
on les écoute il était très virulent et
ont réagi juste après
aujourd'hui il y a trois millions de
réfugiés dans notre pays
en turquie et nous avons dépensé 10
milliards de dollars pour ces trois
millions de personnes jusqu'à maintenant
ces dépenses peuvent être prouvées jus
les factures et c'est sans compter
l'aide des municipalités et des ong
l'union européenne nous avait promis 3
milliards d'euros cela fait maintenant
quatre mois et on attend toujours qu'il
nous le donne cet argent
le premier ministre davutoglu était à
bruxelles j'espère qu'il reviendra avec
cet argent les 3 milliards
regardez d'un côté ils nous disent les
migrants ne doivent pas rentrer en
europe
ok ok on est d'accord mais ce n'est pas
nous qui les envoyons ils viennent de la
mer est malheureusement la plupart
d'entre eux y meurt dans cette mer
jusqu'à maintenant on a sauvé à peu près
cent mille migrants sauvés de la mer
grâce à nos navires
ce qui les tue c'est leur embarcation de
fortune la plupart des migrants meurent
durant la traversée
nous on les sauve c'est là où nous
sommes différents avec les européens
notre façon de traiter les êtres humains
erdogan qui ceux qui se moquent un peu
un peu de l'europe qui laisse mourir
qu'il laisserait mourir
les migrants mer alors que la turquie
elle laisse souvent avec ses navires
bert de rennes c'est le bon partenaire
non mais je crois qu'il ya une chose
qu'il faut dire parce qu on est tombé
dans un piège dans cette année on fait
comme si la question des conséquences de
la déstabilisation de cette région
la syrie mais qui est aussi une
conséquence de la guerre en irak et c
était la responsabilité des européens et
que aussi bien monsieur erdogan que
d'autres qui prennent pas leurs
responsabilités peuvent rejeter le blâme
sur nous c'est absolument faux c'est un
problème mondial
où sont les états unis où sont les
autres pays arabes où sont
éventuellement les russes et d'autres
pays des nations unies donc premièrement
il faut bien répéter à monsieur erdogan
et à d'autres que l'europe attire par sa
prospérité et aussi par ses valeurs
qu'elle fera ce qu'il faut mais qu'elle
n'est pas du tout la seule en cause
deuxièmement les leçons de droits de
l'homme par monsieur erdogan je pense
qu'il faut gentiment le remettre à sa
place
ouais je suis d'accord je viens d'un
pays qui en a sauvé beaucoup plus que la
turquie
donc ce n'est pas l'europe ne sauve pas
l'italie ne sauve pas à l'immigré amer
actuellement il ya tout toute l'europe
qui est de l'italie et la grèce a sauvé
justement mer les migrants qui souvent
sont poussés par les côtes turques et de
trafiquants turc ne nous n'oublions pas
je crois qu est l'une des raisons
positives de cet accord sera le fait que
la turquie agira non plus pour les
pousser vers la grèce ne pourra traiter
sur son territoire la question des
migrants sans essayer de les pousser
vers d'autres d'autres pays
cela dit je crois que
ap / la turquie à refouler les migrants
économiques et les réfugiés de guerre
vers la turquie est ce que c'était la
bonne chose que c'est un pays sûr en
matière de droits de l'homme en matière
de droits de l'homme ce n'est pas un
pays sûr mais comme sylvie le rappeler
elle fait partie de l a signé la
convention des droits de l'homme et ne
l'oublions pas est en train de
d'héberger 3 mio presque 3 millions de
personnes de réfugiés ça il faut il faut
le lui reconnaître et dont dépend c'est
la question c'est éviter que les
migrants arrivent en europe d'une façon
dramatique et tragique pour eux en
essayant à travers des bateaux qui très
souvent ne n'arrive pas qui coule en
essayant d'arriver en europe
à force là on leur dit on traite ici
votre question mais il faut que l'europe
histoire on peut pas laisser ça sera la
turquie on traite ici votre demande et
si vous êtes accepté vous venez en
europe et on organise la distribution
lagacé l'accord doit comprendre la
distribution it l'âge des migrants le
weebe parce qu'à ce moment là c'est des
migrants qui vont des réfugiés qui vont
vers l'europe non plus la grèce ou
l'italie où la croatie ils vont donc je
voulais juste indiquer aussi qu'on parle
beaucoup de la turquie ces jours ci mais
vous avez deux autres pays des régions
qui sont le liban et la jordanie qui
fournissent depuis des années un effort
considérable et qu'il faut aussi garder
ceci à l'esprit donc encore une fois ce
n'est pas un prêt de la gorge en turc
donc c'est pas uniquement l'europe et
enfin le l'union européenne et la
turquie
c'est un problème global situé dans une
région particulièrement déstabiliser et
qui pour laquelle il faudrait trouver
des solutions qui impliquent d'autres
acteurs quand les russes ont bombardé
certains certaines régions de syrie en
créant des flux de réfugiés que monsieur
erdogan avait ouvert ses frontières de
manière à les faire entrer en turquie
pour avoir une monnaie d'échangé avec
l'europe
je crois que tout ça ce sont des
éléments qu'il faut avoir aussi à
l'esprit il faut pas oublier qu'il ya la
libye et aussi sur la côte sur notre
accord sur cet accord qui serait
finalisée dans
une semaine c'est un accord ou c'est du
marchandage ce qu'on a vu les
contreparties elles sont c'est pas rien
plus de visas pour les ressortissants
turcs en europe peu intéressants oui ça
va être possible ça quand on connaît la
population de la turquie 80 millions
exactement c'est à dire l'équivalent de
l'allemagne je ne suis pas sûr que à
moyen terme les conséquences pour tous
les gens qui entrent guinée c'est pas
mon cas mais ont peur de l'invasion de
personnes venant de cette région là le
la négociation soit très favorable donc
encore une fois on sait qu'on va avoir
plus de gens venant d'un atelier minutes
il est notre notre migration des
migrations avec ses toits quand même il
ya 72 critères beaucoup
il est notoire qu'il ya quand même un
certain nombre de demandes qu'il ya par
exemple dans certains pays comme
l'allemagne ou comme l'alsace où nous
trouvons des communautés turques assez
importantes qui peuvent drainer de la
famille etc
donc je pense encore une fois c'est un
élément qu'il faut garder à l'esprit et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut attendre de
voir si le l'accord sera conclu
bon ça c'est en tout cas ce ne sera pas
un accord qui augmente les possibilités
de migration c'est un accord de libre
circulation qui va avec un processus qui
est c'est vrai est interrompue mais un
processus qui dure depuis longtemps
d'adhésion de la turquie à l'union
européenne
marc personnellement je suis favorable à
l'intégration de la turquie dans l'union
européenne si elle pourra démontrer de
respecter vraiment les droits de l'homme
la liberté de la presse
donc ça on sait qu'on a vendu cette
addition c'est qu'on a vendu cette
adhésion de la turquie à l'union
européenne à gauche que l'adhésion la
turquie à l'union européenne ne viendra
jamais très sincèrement je pense que les
conditions ne sont pas requises et que
surtout le problème c'est pas la turquie
c'est l'autre partie c'est à dire que si
l'idée c'est de faire entrer la turquie
dans le premier cercle de l'union
européenne seul à le détruire est
totalement apprécions ce orient
notamment vu ce qui se passe avec le
royaume uni vers une europe qui pourrait
être composé d'un cercle plus étroit
plus intégrée politiquement et d'un
deuxième cercle beaucoup plus lâches
à ce moment là des pays comme la turquie
l'ukraine les balkans ont peut-être
vocation à y entrer mais j'espère en
tout cas parce que j'ai pris position là
dessus il ya des années que on ne va pas
nous refaire en douche
le coût de l'adhésion de la turquie
c'est un sujet trop important pour le
glisser dans les valises des réfugiés si
j'ose dire il faut quand même que j'ai
des choses très rapidement parce
qu'effectivement on devrait avoir une
europe à deux vitesses une europe
politique
une europe élargie qui devra donner
réponse à tous les pays des balkans qui
attendent dans d'entamer un processus
d'adhésion et donc puisque je suis
d'accord qu'on ne peut on peut pas
imaginer une europe politique avec tous
ces pays on a besoin d'une europe
premiers cercles politiques fédérales
intégré et d'une europe large qui cela
essentiellement en grande marché mais
non seulement marché est liée aussi ont
respecté droits de l'homme et les
critères d'adhésion à l'union
voilà pour le dossier des migrants
l'autre actualité en france c'est manuel
valls qui va tenter de modifier le code
du travail
un autre pays européen à lancer un train
de réformes c'est l'italie 1 son premier
ministre a d'ailleurs affiché une forme
de complicité de similitudes avec le
premier ministre français ainsi
l'italien matteo renzi comme manuel
valls le président du conseil des
ministres italien est prêt à bousculer
pour gouverner un exemple sa réforme du
sénat a pour plus de stabilité
gouvernementale
ainsi naquit passe de 315 à 100
sénateurs et qui n'a plus le dernier mot
le reportage à rome de françois goulard
il l'a fait matteo renzi a réussi ce que
les italiens croyaient impossible faire
voter par les sénateurs eux mêmes une
révolution de leurs vieilles
institutions le palazzo madama siège du
sénat à rome est depuis des années
source d'instabilité permanente l'eau
quand les lois
refusant la confiance au gouvernement et
contraignant parfois un premier ministre
à la démission
matteo renzi lors de sa prise de
fonction avait annoncé la couleur
devant les sénateurs notre pays est
rouillée c'est un pays embourbé enchaîné
par une bureaucratie asphyxiante
je vais vous le dire avec la franchise
qui me caractérise je veux être le
dernier président du conseil a demandé
la confiance à cette assemblée le pavé
dans la mare avait fait des remous dans
le monde politique italien
mais deux ans plus tard la réforme est
passée les sénateurs ont accepté d'être
trois fois moins nombreux et que ce soit
l'assemblée qui est le dernier lors du
vote d'une loi caisse à la composent un
nouveau sénat composé de conseillers
régionaux élus par les citoyens
aujourd'hui les sénateurs 1 315 ils
seront désormais sans ses conseillers
régionaux s'occuperont principalement
des sujets concernant les entités
territoriales la navette parlementaire
sera des plus grands noms simplifier le
passage entre l'assemblée et le sénat
la fameuse double lecture
mais comment le président du conseil s'y
est il pris pour faire ce tour de
passe-passe institutionnel avec des
sénateurs qui posent leur propre tête
sur le billot pour convaincre les
sénateurs matteo renzi leur a mis la
pression en leur tenant le discours
suivant vous avez l'opportunité de faire
prendre au système politique un virage
historique
il leur a répété à plusieurs reprises il
cherchait son fait à mobiliser leur
conscience politique
les sénateurs ont fini par penser qu'il
pouvait être les acteurs d'un changement
que les italiens attendent depuis 40 ans
sur la place sainte stack you le
rendez-vous des politiques pour le
traditionnel café du matin
certains ont du mal à avaler la réforme
surtout le président de la commission
censée examiner le texte
mais court circuité par le premier
ministre les réformes constitutionnelles
doivent obligatoirement être discuté en
commission renzi est passé au dessus des
lois il a emmené la réforme directement
dans l'hémicycle il est passé outre les
règles pour exercer une forme de
dictature
lui il n'est l'élu de personnes il n'a
aucun électeur il est issu des métiers
de la communication il n'a pas la force
du nombre est là la force dictatorial de
faire ces gestes inconstitutionnelle
matteo renzi apporter la discorde jusque
dans les rangs de son parti démocrate
c'est grâce aux voix de la droite
berlusconienne et de l'extrême droite
qu'il a fait voter sa réforme
certains auraient préféré la suppression
pure et simple du sénat car il apparaît
à leurs yeux comme une potiche
plus personne ne touchera au sénat
présent il restera tel qu'on ait quelque
chose à mi chemin entre un musée un
cimetière des éléphants et une chambre
une influence pour conseillers régionaux
qui veulent encore compter à rome ils
deviendront des hommes politiques au
milieu de tous les autres les plus
invisible auprès des électeurs d'italie
dernière étape pour le texte un passage
devant l'assemblée au mois d'avril une
formalité vu la majorité confortable qui
soutient le gouvernement mais matteo
renzi a promis un référendum pour
inscrire la loi dans la constitution
il aura lieu en octobre 2016 et pour lui
c'est quitte ou double si c'est le nom
qui l'emportent
il démissionne
voilà un reportage de françois goulard
est-ce qu'il a eu raison de réformer le
sénat
matteo renzi il y avait un accord depuis
très longtemps à l'intérieur de notre
parti est en réalité dans une large
partie de l'opinion publique et des
partis au parlement de réformer le sénat
sur base régionale donc dans le faire à
senna des régions et des collectivités
territoriales un peu sur le modèle du
bundesrat
mais sans les exécutifs mais avec des
élus régionaux et locaux
donc c'est tout à fait ce qu'on voulait
et je crois que le peuple italien
confirmera par le référendum qui
d'ailleurs produit par la constitution
dans ce cas le résultat
moi je suis pas fait de mal satisfait
tech pas que ça c'est des petits jeux
politiques sylvie goulard matteo renzi
manuel valls et les frères jumeaux de la
social démocratie européenne
bah il faudrait que monsieur valls fasse
le même genre de réformes que monsieur
renzi et là on pourrait alors y aller à
la rêverie du job act du jack tu es la
réforme du marché du travail pour
simplifier monsieur monsieur orange a
réussi plusieurs choses après il ya des
aspects sur lesquels on peut se poser
des questions mais factuellement il a
rajeuni la classe politique de son pays
et il a fait un certain nombre de
réformes dans celle centrale dont vous
venez de parler je sais pas si les
français ça se fait le job
acné en gros c'est une réforme du droit
du travail du type de celle que manuel
valls est en train de tenter et qui à
mon avis va dans le bon sens
la différence c'est que on peut se
demander si en france on ira jusque là
plus de plus de cdd mais quelques il y
avait plus de plus de cdd des cdc et
faciliter le licenciement de manière à
ce que la reprise n'est pas la peur
d'embaucher parce que ça c'est une des
choses qu'il faut répéter aux français
il est faux de dire qu'il n'y a pas de
lien entre les modalités du licenciement
et les modalités de l'embauché si une
entreprise à un moment donné c'est
qu'elle est prisonnière pour que jamais
avec un salarié recruté sur une mauvaise
base ou avec un retournement de
conjoncture
c'est défavorable pour l'emploi donc il
y a un lien entre la possibilité de
licencier qui doit pas être non plus
excessives et la possibilité d'embauché
on a des chiffres mercedes bresso
c'est bien sur le front du chômage que
l'incident de matteo renzi et manuel
valls divergent de plus car depuis plus
d'un an le chef du gouvernement italien
a réussi à faire baisser ce fléau de la
péninsule 13,1 pour cent en 2014 on
passe à 11,4 en 2016 alors qu'en france
le chômage a été moins élevé il n'a
quasiment pas baissé sur la même période
il faut pas oublier qu'on a aussi
modifié la qualité du travail parce que
les travaux à temps indéterminé les
emplois à temps déterminé augmentent et
diminuent un peu ce attendre déterminé
donc le job act fait son boulot qui
n'est pas seulement celui de faire
augmenter les emplois les emplois
augmentent s'il ya croissance et donc
c'est d'autres mesures que reims est
repris qui sont en train de relancer un
peu la croissance mais mieux l'art ça
sert à améliorer la qualité des emplois
en éliminant les excès parce que les
excès de garantie empêcher les
employeurs d'embaucher un temps
déterminé c'est ça qui a fait le job et
c'est très positif
il ya une même critique quand même bon
on vers manuel valls et matteo renzi
favoriserait trop les patrons au
détriment des salariés
mais les entreprises qui créent les
emplois faut qu'on arrête avec cette
idéologie en france ça n'a aucun sens
favoriser les patrons c'est un cetain se
trouve que c'est un vocabulaire je ne
suis pas pour vous favorisez
d'entreprise et glisse entreprise vient
de quelqu'un solaris embauche il
favorisé des entreprises favoriser la
création d'emplois et des les
travailleurs avoir des emplois stables
je crois que les trois choses vont
ensemble c'est les entreprises qui
créent des emplois
d'accord donc vous pouvoir donc le job
act pouvoir plutôt le le verre à moitié
plein que le verre à moitié vide achir
marc nassian à le vert est plus qu à
moitié plein il est embellie économique
est due aussi à des des effets externes
à la baisse du prix du pétrole
pour les choix importants pour l'esprit
de téléspectateurs français de souligner
qu' on dit souvent que c'est une sorte
de modèle allemand qui domine en europe
c'est complètement faux si vous regarder
quels sont les pays qui ont fait des
réformes du marché du travail poussé
vous avez l'italie vous avez l'espagne
vous avez une partie du nord de l'europe
et dans tous ces pays
ça s'est amélioré c'est surtout ça qu'il
faut dire aux gens il faut avoir le
courage de franchir cette étape de
manière à ce que nos jeunes notamment
retrouvent du travail dernier mot je
suis d'accord je crois que les la
croissance repart si on fait des
investissements
c'est là aussi que rennes qui a fait a
fait beaucoup mais évidemment pour que
les entreprises investissent il faut que
le marché du travail ça marchait qui est
acceptable et ce qui va pas trop vite
matteo renzi dans sa stratégie sera
bousculé patronat besoin d'aller à noter
la belle au bois dormant elle s'est
réveillée elle marche assez vite je
pense qu'elle doit courir deux cas merci
mesdames d'avoir accepté notre
invitation merci sylvie goulard d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci mercedes
bresso d'être venu assez la fin de repas
bio merci à vous de nous avoir suivis et
bonne suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires et la rtbf
ciao